the fundamental problem is that humans
are extracting fossil carbon from the
curve in the forms of oil natural gas
coal etc and we're taking that fossil
carbon and we burn it and it goes into
the biosphere that fossil carbon has
been there for many millions of years
safely stored in the earth so the
climate Earth's climate depends
delicately on how much carbon is in the
biosphere essentially how much co2 in
the atmosphere and what we're doing is
we're introducing tremendous vast
quantities of carbon that were safely
stored in the earth and we're
introducing them to the biosphere it's
really that simple you're just adding
carbon the carbon becomes co2 in the
atmosphere you know global warming has
been around in the sort of scientific
literature for a number of decades now
and there's been an awful lot of
research on it and of course we don't
understand everything about and global
warming and climate change but we do
understand the basics by introducing
more carbon in the environment you
generally raised the carbon dioxide co2
levels of the atmosphere and the
fundamental thing that the problem is
that the co2 absorbs energy and heats
the atmosphere it's very simple physics
it's not debated so that's the that's
what fundamentally what's going on
there's a variability in the way the
climate system operates so from year to
year the temperature changes anyway but
there's not what trend we can see from
when the Industrial Revolution started
actually human start to make lots of co2
off around about point eight degrees
maybe a little more there's a lot of
variability in this era the recent past
has been disgusted this thing called
hiatus which is a supposed slowdown in
global warming but it looks like um this
year we'll probably the warmest on
record by a long long long long way but
difficulty a scientific difficulty is
that generally the science has an error
bar in of a factor of two like if you
read studies the earth will warm by two
to four degrees we just can't nail it
down any better than that this the
science is fairly complicated there are
lots of things that
into the carbon so it's just a problem
we have to live with that we don't know
whether it's two degrees or four degrees
or off into the future whether it's four
degrees or HP's there's this error bar
that's that's pretty big we just have to
live with well I mean we're looking I'm
you know cop21 is focused on limiting
global 122 degrees C that's going to be
very challenging and you know we may be
looking under some of the business as
usual scenarios at 48 or even six
degrees warming with respect to
pre-industrial by the end of the century
and I think that really means no
significant perturbations to the earth
system we carry on going the way we're
going there we are probably going to we
would definitely below the two-degree
target that the international
negotiations are talking about out of
the water and there's a danger we make
it 24 degrees so you're four degrees
Sofia four degrees globally is bad news
but it means that over land where we
happen to live you're looking at more
like five degrees so quite often the way
we frame this whole issue about climate
change sort of downplays it we take
averages over the globe which means that
you know two thirds of the globe is
water you're mostly getting the sea and
the sea doesn't warm up as fast as the
land so even two degrees it's quite
significant because it means three or
four degrees it means maybe more than an
in the Arctic big big changes so without
that you get all the usual associated
effects without dealing with climate
change you get the Associated effects of
warming sea level rise due to just just
seawater expanding as you heat it up and
I cheat meal that also can complete a
signal in sea level rise you get changed
in the hydrological cycle so when the
planets warmer and more waters help in
the atmosphere that means that when it
does rain it tends to be heavier rain so
more floods but also evaporations faster
that's hotter so you tend to get dry
periods get dry regions and periods
getting dry so there's a tendency for
hydrological extremes to increase many
changes in rainfall patterns you know
she changes in storms all sorts of
things that we know about many other
things that we don't know about there
are many unknown unknowns there are
there are other problems that things
that we don't know about tipping points
like we could get to a point where the
climate shifts dramatically we just
don't know if that's possible or where
we happen we don't understand everything
about and global warming and climate
change but we do understand the basics
so I think the the basic understanding
of global warming is sufficient for the
politicians to be able to make decisions
I don't think it's the science that's
necessarily holding up process on earth
and the second thing about global
warming is it although it's not it's not
yet very large compared to geological
changes it's very very fast the changes
we can detect from the geological record
from ice cores are often bigger but
they're much slower